Không báo lệ viếng lệ truy dạo và lệ ăn tăng đồng chi trình đất lương.
Muên ở vế bộ chiến trị, muên trở tích nước cộng hà sợ chúng nghĩa Việt Nam,
lệ tăng đồng chi trình đất lương được tổ chức theo nghỉ thức lệ Quốc tăng.
Lên kế ổ đồng chi trình đất lương được quan tại nhà tăng lệ Cú sa Sun năm trình thánh tông thay vô hà đội.
Lệ viếng đồng chi trình đất lương được tổ chức tại nhà tăng lệ Cú sa Sun năm trình thánh tông thay vô hà đội.
Lệ ăn tăng lúc mười lăm giờ cùng ngay, tạng vế chân cua nhà sả phụ khán thị giả nước phổ tình quan ái.
Bùng thời gian tăng đồng chi trình đất lương được tăng đồng chi trình thông thay.
Lệ tăng lệ Cú sa Sun năm trình thánh tông thay vô hà đội.
Lệ ăn tăng lúc mười lăm giờ cùng ngay, tạng dễ trang cua nhà, sã phổ khán thị giả nước phổ tình quảng ái.
Bộ trường thống nhất thành phố Ho Chi Minh và tại vội trường tên năm người bộ trí viết
con sự tình quảng Ngái, số một trăm bố mấy hai lê trung đình, thành phố quảng Ngái,
cũng sẽ giả lệ viếng lễ truy điệp đồng chi trình đức lương.
Đại truyền Việt Nam và đại tình nói Việt Nam sẽ tưởng tật chức tiếp, lệ viếng lễ truy điệp
và lệ ăn tác đồng chi trình đức lương. Tại thành phố Hàn Đội, thành phố Ho Chi Minh và tình quảng Ngái.
Chồng 2 ngày diễn xa lệ cuốc tăng đồng chi trình đức lương,
muyên uống bộ tríng trị, muyên trự tính nước cộng hà sả hội trung với Việt Nam.
Ngái hai mấy tư và hai mấy lâm thằng năm năm ngày cũng trăm hai mấy lâm.
Các cơ quan công sờ, nơi công cộng chiều cơ dù, không tự trước các hoạt động vui trời giải trí.
Bắt lệ tăng.